So for this quiz, I want you to think carefully about a strategy that will be
the most effective way to finish the problem. We've got a lot of different
things we might do next. We don't necessarily need to do all of these, and the
order in which we do them will make a big difference in how efficiently and
correctly we solve the problem. So, I want you to think about this and give an
answer that lists the steps you would do in order. And an example to show you
the format for the answer is just to put the letters in order. This is not a
correct answer, but note that you can include some of the steps more than once,
and you don't need to include all of the steps. This is pretty tricky, and I
don't expect you to match exactly what I think the best answer is. But there's
several different ways to answer this that would be accepted, and you should be
able to come up with one of those. So, see if you can order these steps.